[Music]
dude
uh friday night friday
night i had one of the drunkest crowds
i've had in a minute there's like this
group of women that came in from like
massachusetts they were like celebrating
a divorce i was about to go on stage and
i heard them coming in and they were
already drunk just like
chirping and like as they were making
their way to their table they're like
kind of already heckling
my guys zayad was opening so by the time
i get up there i'm in this weird pocket
where like they're drunk and kind of
they're tuning out of the show so
they're like talking in the back of the
room then there's these two girls in
front of me they're nice but like as
they start drinking and like getting
deeper in the show
one of the one of them
is
not making the connection on my jokes so
then there's like this delay where every
time i tell a joke
this girl in front of me would explain
the joke to her friend as i'm trying to
move on to the next thing then there was
a table of people who were just kind of
buzzed and they were kind of behaving
like they were watching a youtube video
at home like they're like kind of
lightly commentating on the set then
talking to each other and then it's just
a weird mix and then there were people
who just wanted to see the show so i'm
like doing this weird balancing act
where i'm like doing some material
that i do crowd work
and by the end of it i literally cut
half my material i'm like all right i'm
just gonna
just talk [ __ ] to the crowd now oh no
way yeah
i just ended up being like
it's a crowd work set
but it went well
yeah yeah it went good you know by the
end of it the girls the women in the
back were like literally trying to fight
people they were like
like during the show and like
yeah like they were drunk and just going
at it like someone tried to shush them
they did not have that they were like
[ __ ] you
don't [ __ ] look at me comedy is
something that's great when you're
buzzed
but not when you're drunk no
no it's not good it's not what you want
you want music yeah you want something
that's more stimulating you know you
don't want to like think like i remember
dude i went to [ __ ] i was in
san diego when bo burnham was touring
his uh netflix special i don't know why
i don't know why i don't know maybe we
were day drinking or something like that
but for some reason i got
so wasted before the show i was blacked
out
and
the only thing i remember is
remember like the the finals kanye style
song he does where he's all auto-tuned
and singing about pringles
sort of i
wept i cried like a little baby like not
not not laughing i crows crying yes
because it moved me truly
damn
like what the [ __ ] damn what's wrong
with you dudes are like dude are you
good i was like
over a song about [ __ ] pringles
[Music]
someone someone is at
someone evidenced you as to or like used
you as evidence as to why
the show was so good you know like
someone left that night and they're like
how was it like dude
it was crazy it was funny this guy next
to me like
he must have been going through
something because when beau did the
pringles thing like he he just like
broke down and it was kind of beautiful
man
it's like the pringles thing but that
wasn't sad at all i know i don't know
what it was i guess it was the auto-tune
just really got to him i don't know yeah
[Music]
so stupid i felt so stupid afterwards
because i woke up the next morning i was
like why did i do that like i
i he's one of my favorite comedians
right now i don't remember the show
that's not something you want to do it's
not those two things don't mix yeah yeah
wasted and comedy just it just doesn't
really
and it's funny like as you know just
doing the clubs
i always encounter this there's always
inevitably
a table of strangers that wanders in
and they get like the last table and
they just start drinking and they're
kind of in and out of the show
um
in kansas city there's this table of
like uh older like
gen x type people and they were pretty
they were very [ __ ] up
it was kind of endearing one of them was
[ __ ] up but he was just like looking
to the stage smiling the whole time okay
like he had like a look in his eyes just
like he was he was enjoying himself so i
think he was buzzed okay but his boys
weren't
and and like i think a couple of them
had their girlfriends there
so like at the end of the show i like
looked at them and i'm like oh did you
guys have a good time and one of them
was like yeah but tell me why they told
us to be quiet and i was like uh
i don't know dude i
i didn't hear anything right so then
like i'm kind of like working the crowd
a little bit i could just hear him to
the left like getting aggro with one of
the waiters
and something that's important is comedy
clubs
they do this thing where they they hire
only a select amount of people and i
realized why all the comedy clubs only
serve like chicken tenders and fries and
fried chicken sandwiches it's because
they don't actually want to hire cooks
so everyone there has to wear multiple
hats like at the last club i was at this
weekend the girl doing sound was also
delivering drinks it was the craziest
[ __ ] ever whoa but then like so when
some drunk [ __ ] is in there and he's
like why the [ __ ] you know just getting
all turned up and i i just feel so i
feel for the wait staff so much i'm like
dude
this is just like some 19 year old
like girl in college
like
she has to be the fry cook and then
be security and then deliver drinks like
just like [ __ ] and then get up and do
five too yeah and get up and do your eye
opener
when the show's over like
give this [ __ ] person a break dude
that's such a funny
thing to get mad about why do they tell
me to be quiet i know right show dude
you're not supposed to be talking ever
[Music]
but you know what they're like i'm not
even i'm not even loud
i'm not even [ __ ] loud
[Music]
it's like yeah you are man
but other than that i mean like yeah
second night was dope as hell um
i mean connecticut is beautiful i was
just joking around saying i'm never
going to hartford because everyone
messaged me being like uh oh dude don't
come here hartford sucks so i was just
like kind of playing into it and then
like i tweeted that [ __ ] and then
some lady who's like claimed to be like
a public defender of hartford which like
you know you think lawyer but then i
just realized i think she just publicly
defends hartford
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] she's searching hartford on
twitter seeing what people are saying
literally random people
well actually we have a really nice
library bro she was like actually the
parks here are really nice
on the contrary she looked up the club i
was at and she was like you're not even
in hartford you're in you're in
manchester in a strip mall if you said
this in hartford she's like you might
say that crap there and they'll laugh if
you say it in hartford you'd say no more
and i'm like dude a public defender is
threatening me for talking [ __ ] about
hartford i'm definitely never going to
hartford like you
and then i was laughing because what
offender i know right that's so good and
then i then i asked people in the crowd
i'm like who's from hartford and like
some people raise their hands i'm like
i'm pretty sure if i went there and i
said i'm never coming back here like you
guys would agree and then they're like
yeah we would like
no one likes it there so it was just
crazy yeah i was just like i was joking
about her like being batman like for
hartford
like she just
she like tracks us to our like hotel and
i just wake up in the middle of the
night and she just has like a shoddy
mask on and she's like don't [ __ ]
talk [ __ ] about hartford it just punches
me in the balls and then leaves
oh
you